[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient par
les sports votre feuilleton préféré sur
le sport local dans ce quatrième épisode
de la saison 3 y aura comme l'abeille
d'habitués de des analyses des débats et
des duels acharnés entre nos experts sur
différents thèmes pendant près d'une
heure aujourd'hui quatre super héros du
sport local sont présents sur ce plateau
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite par l'un des personnages heures
de cette émission sont donnés le
comparer à un super héros ce serait sans
nul doute possible à flash il est aussi
rapide que lui sur son vélo de
compétition de vitesse qui lui permet
d'engranger à les médailles mondiales en
cyclisme sur piste dans la catégorie à
master ce le capitaine yann dujarrier
est avec nous sur ce plateau mont saint
michel
bonjour yann vous allez bien très bien
alors en un petit cadeau pour vous
regardez cette petite photo qui va
apparaître à l'écran
voilà flash merci ça parce que vous avez
tout à fait de je suis pas je suis pas
peur de marvel mais c'est un en étant
mais je vais tout à fait vraiment encore
une fois comme la musique ou queen est
un de mes groupes favoris
voilà tout est prêt pour vous sur cette
émission il ya peu on passe de l'autre
côté à musique c'est une légende de ce
taux qui nous vient tout droit de
l'étoile sportive de trappes si on
devait le comparer un super-héros une
figure nous vient tout de suite en tête
ce serait iron man le super héros qui
arrive à sauver le monde grâce à son
armure ladies gentlemen mustapha
larfaoui est avec nous bonjour mustapha
quant à la joue là bas je vais très très
bien surtout quand l'émission commence
comme ça si vous devez aussi vous devez
vous qualifiez vous par contre c'est
qu'effectivement vous arrivez à nous
trouver tous ces superlatifs à chaque
fois et ça change à chaque fois et
pourtant ça nous positionne donc nous on
aime bien ne changeait rien même en
rester là et c'est mon super pouvoirs
c'est exact alors on est forcément en
période d'halloween en ce moment et on a
retrouvé le costume que vous avez porté
le 31 octobre dernier
évidemment on va la regarder voilà voilà
c'est pas parce que vous ouais non mais
je vais bientôt 18 un petit peu de temps
en temps sur les réseaux sociaux jouent
à ça mais c'est le propre des réseaux
sociaux c'est effectivement de de fuiter
on repasse à ma droite musique qui nous
vient tout droit du club de football
américain des temps qui est d'elancourt
club dans lequel il est directeur
sportif comme le personnage de thor il
arrive à allier force physique et force
mentale pendant les matchs de foot us
converser situations à périlleuse est
mal engagée bonjour frédéric bonjour à
tous alors c'est toujours un immense
plaisir de vous recevoir sur son plateau
nous mêmes alors pour vous aussi voilà
on a en un petit cadeau un petit photos
à vous proposer on va la regarder juste
rêvera l'écran à la toison d'or très
réaliste pareil personnage que vous
affectionnez un jeu mieux aussi voilà
vous êtes un peu notre tort sur cette
émission on termine ce tour de table
à ma gauche musique qui nous vient du
rugby-club de versailles un petit
nouveau dans cette émission mais ne vous
fiez pas à son apparence dans les duels
il va se transformer en hulk pour
emporter les débats face à ses
adversaires
mesdames et messieurs le gaillard pire
chevalier membre du bureau du rugby-club
de versailles est avec nous pendant une
heure pour cette émission
bonjour pierre c'est du michael salut à
tous alors vous êtes le petit nouveau de
de cette aventure on a un cadeau de
bienvenue justement pour vous on va
regarder tout de suite ce petit cadeau
voilà le hulk dont vous ferez mieux en
tout cas autour de cette table
il est très difficile à battre en duel
le plus le petit bleu qui devient qui
deviendrait en fait exactement ma rage
vraisemblable 4 alors avant de passer au
programme de l'émission j'aimerais qu'on
parle rapidement de la très belle
performance du club de vélizy 78 aux
derniers championnats du monde masters
ce qui se sont déroulées aux états unis
à début octobre et notamment de vous
yann jarrier vous voit à l'écran vous
avez réussi à remporter deux médailles
sur cette compétition
il a été deux fois vice champion du
monde ou super souvenir yann
non ça aurait été un super souvenir si
j'avais ramené huit médailles d'or voilà
donc là c'est un c'est un très bon
souvenir c'est c'est c'est juste voie là
bas il faut encore continuer de
travailler pour pour aller chercher pour
aller chercher ce fameux c'est ce fameux
maillot je suis arrivé avec eux
au top de ma forme je fais des très beau
chrono par équipes par exemple on assure
l'un de mes équipes
il ya deux ans on était vice champion du
monde déjà à manchester
on a établi une performance qui était
une seconde une seconde et demie plus
rapide et on finit toujours vice
champion du monde les australiens ont
qui n'était pas présent les sur les
élisons précédé éditions précédentes ont
fait un chrono
personne n'était jamais passée en
dessous de 38 secondes de 48 secondes
chez les masters pour pour un titre de
champion du monde
nous avec 48 48 2 bat on aurait on
aurait pu on aurait pu être champion du
monde l'année dernière et l'année
précédente là donc une très belle
performance mais donc voilà on ne peut
pas avoir de regret on est tombé sur les
avait des adversaires plus forts que
nous
voilà maintenant le commence déjà même
si mais si on était plusieurs à vouloir
lever le pied pour pour les saisons à
venir
pour profiter un peu de famille ben
voilà on commence déjà à penser à penser
à l'année prochaine et à se projeter
vers pour aller chercher à essayer
d'aller chercher à nouveau cette
médaille et ce titre qui nous qui nous
fait rêver qui nous fait hurler et qui
nous permet d'avancer au quotidien de
tout contenu et de travailler c'est vrai
que que ben on a et on est une bande de
potes maintenant ça fait ça c'est des
cdd des épreuves qu'on prépare depuis
quatre ans on voit qu on progresse on
on prend énormément de plaisir on a
beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés parce
qu'on n'a pas de moyens on a très peu de
moyens on n'est pas accompagnée par la
fédération
on n'est pas mais bon c'est la même
chose pour beaucoup de master peut pas
tous mais pour beaucoup de master on
n'est pas aidé par les fédérations on
est on est pas on n'est pas suivi
mais mais voilà on a envie on a on a
envie de pouvoir mettre des choses en
place on a on a envie de continuer et
donc ben voilà on est en se nourrissant
se nourrit de ça au quotidien et
j'espère que j'espère qu'on arrivera à
obtenir la médaille d'or et comment
expliquez-vous ian rapidement cette
réussite voilà du club de vélizy 78 dans
la catégorie masters
je pense que l'ambiance simplement une
ambiance ont beaucoup de gens nous
voient régulièrement vélodrome quand
même
il ya très peu de créneaux au vélodrome
des créneaux abonnés bien sûr où il n'ya
pas de d'adhérents de vélizy enfin c'est
rare de voir un créneau sans un minimum
un adhérent vénitien et ensuite ben
voilà on se prend pas la tête on s'amuse
on est vraiment une bande de potes tout
le monde tout le monde s'entraide les
uns les uns des autres
alors c'est vrai que vont sur un sur un
championnat comme comme celui là l'est
où la distance est très très fins et
très très loin et à los angeles
c'est compliqué demandé beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens mais mais sur un
championnat d'europe on a déjà eu qu'a
eu lieu à roubaix au mois de septembre
on a eu un été très nombreux à pouvoir
se déplacer et on a eu de très bons
résultats et essayer voilà c'est parce
que l'ambiance est bonne
tout le monde ce conseil et puis au fur
et à mesure on acquiert de plus en plus
d'expérience et on la répercutent à des
nouveaux qui viennent chez nous parce
qu'ils voient que les résultats sont là
donc
donc voilà c'est je pense que le maître
mot c'est vraiment l'ambiance qui règne
au sein de ce club qui est qui est
vraiment une ambiance une ambiance
amicale et tous souhaitent tout
simplement aux amicales alors les
pistards du club de vélizy 78 qu'on
pourra retrouver ce dimanche 5 novembre
vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour le quatrième grand prix de
vélizy plus de 150 coureurs sont
attendus pour la compétition dont vous
il ya bien sûr s'assurer que nous on a
déjà repris l'entraînement pour pour
être un minimum compétitif ce qu'on a
quand même coupé un petit peu après
après championnats du monde on est resté
une semaine de plus ça aux états unis
mais rapidement rapidement il a fallu
reprendre pour être pour être performant
dimanche
alors on va passer maintenant au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de boxe avec ce grand gala
programmé le 11 novembre prochain au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les boxeurs de
la team farrugia d'elancourt seront sur
le ring zag et nous allons également
parler de voile avec le départ de la
transat jacques vabre le robot little
louie button partira en duo avec sa
femme servane escoffier sur cette
compétition
les avants de développer ces thèmes nous
allons parler encore et toujours de
cyclisme
direction les championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste qui se sont déroulés
à mi octobre à berlin l'équipe de france
a réalisé une superbe compétition en
remportant huit médailles dont cinq en
or
parmi les principales sensation
sébastien vigier le pistard qui
s'entraîne presque tous les jours sur la
piste de saint quentin en yvelines a
remporté à seulement 20 ans la plus
belle des médailles en vitesse
individuelle
il s'est également illustré en montant
sur la plus haute marche du podium en
vitesse par équipes avec les inimités un
quentin lafargue et benjamin edelin le
trappistes benjamin thomas a quant à lui
raflé l'or sur l'épreuve de poursuite
par équipes lors sur l'américaine et le
bronze sur l'épreuve de l'omnium à cinq
points de l'espagnol albert torres dans
la dernière journée chez les filles
mathilde de gros a obtenu la médaille
d'argent en vitesse individuelle battu
en finale par l'allemand de christina
vos gueules la seule médaille chez les
féminines à son retour de la compétition
nous avons eu la réaction de quentin
lafargue médaille de bronze sur le
kilomètre est également médaille d'or en
vitesse par équipes
on écoute on est au niveau des des
meilleurs résultats mondiaux de la
saison dernière sans pour autant
comparer parce que tout est difficile de
comparer d'année en année etc
mais voilà nous on bat le record petit à
petit et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est
très très encourageant pour la suite
chez les féminines je le disais à
précédemment une seule médaille a été
collectée pour ces championnats d'europe
celle en argent de la nouvelle pépite du
sprint français mathilde de gros une
belle performance qui sont elle va lui
permettre de grandir et d'emmagasiner de
l'expérience on les écoute
globalement c'est positif après je
regarde toujours les points négatifs
pour pouvoir les améliorer du coup là on
a vu tous les plains
mauvais on va dire technique pour
essayer de mieux faire
au prochaine coupe du monde l'a déjà le
fait de courir déjà en quarts de finale
contre des filles où il ya que même pas
deux dixièmes d'écart
les matchs sont beaucoup plus serrées et
là le physique ça va plus fin ça suffit
plus il faut savoir bien courir et là
j'étais obligé de savoir bien courir
du coup j'ai pris énormément en
expérience et j'espère en pas enfin
apprendre encore plus sur les coupes du
monde qui arrive je le disais
précédemment quentin lafargue a brillé
benjamin et de l'ain a brillé également
mathilde gros ils ont tous entre 18 et
26 ans la question sur ce thème la
nouvelle génération est elle déjà à
maturité oui ou non
oui ou non pour voter comme d'habitude
oui non on va faire un petit duel entre
vous mustapha et ferait qu'anderson ali
mustafa vous êtes en désaccord et
commence c'est juste que je me suis
placé en désaccord avec tout le monde
pour donner de l'optimisme à ce groupe
et montrer qu'effectivement ça commence
toujours comme ça sert qu on en débat
aujourd'hui et les résultants les aura
plus tard et vous verrez que j'avais
raison
or c'est essentiellement des vidéos
comme celle essentiellement pour ça je
suis pas un grand spécialiste de cette
discipline
en revanche on voit bien comment ça
commence à poindre on voit bien comment
les choses sont en train de se mettre en
place et c'est souvent comme ça que les
grande aventure commence
on parlait alors du club de de vélizy
ont parlé diane en particulier on a un
président qui a parlé des premiers de
cordée il ya des premiers de peloton il
ya des premiers comme ça dans chaque
catégorie que ce soit dans des clubs il
ya toujours des gens comme ça qui sont
des moteurs qui sont des locomotives
même si on parle que de vélo aujourd'hui
et donc c'est comme ça que les grandes
aventures sportives se mettre en place
moi là j'y crois parce que je il ya
vraiment tous les ingrédients pour aller
vers une ce type de ce type de bonheur
qu'on aura tout ça à partager je prends
le pari ici puisque c'est une émission
on se dit les choses franchement et où
souvent il ya des flashbacks donc
j'attends
la prochaine émission on pourra dire
voilà le préfet les laumes du vélodrome
pardon et vous verrez qu encore une fois
nous avions raison parce que je sais que
vous le partagez mon opinion miquel
évidemment prêt n'est qu'un personnes
moi ce qui me dérange dans l'idée de
maturité c'est que cette idée qu'ils
atteignaient un plafond et que ils
progresseront plus tant que ça parce
qu'une fois qu'on est à maturité à la
marge de progression se réduit si on
n'est pas encore arrivé à maturité et
c'est vrai qu'ils sont tellement jeune
et c'est vrai que c'est impressionnant
parce qu'ils ont des résultats dès
maintenant mais ça montre en fait ça
révèle le talent qui possède déjà et on
voit que ils sont pas près d'arriver à
maturité tout de suite et ils sont 18
printemps
ils ont même pas fait complètement leur
croissance de grandes villes ne sont pas
encore tout à fait adultes et c'est vrai
que de ce point de vue là seulement et
on peut on peut on peut dire qu'ils sont
pas encore à maturité et puis après une
carrière c'est long ça se construit
petit à petit et c'est vrai que quand on
a qu'un ou deux ans d'expérience à ce
niveau là on peut pas on peut on peut
pas établir qui sont déjà à leur limite
donc à eux de continuer de travailler de
continuer de performer de progresser de
est de montrer que au final ils n'ont
pas de limites et qu'ils arriveront à
maturité quand ils en auront une
trentaine d'années peut-être je vais
demander à notre spécialiste cyclisme de
trancher il ya déjà riez couple est tous
d'accord qu est ce que le staff a vous a
conquis
optimise c'est le début et ils vont ils
ont ils vont faire encore mieux plus
tard ça je suis d'accord et je suis
encore plus d'accord avec avec frédéric
on peut pas être à maturité à 20 ans je
vais juste rappeler que chris hoy a été
champion olympique du keirin à 35 ans
donc ils ont encore énormément de
carrière c'est l'on soit une carrière de
cycliste sur piste et une carrière d'une
carte de cyclistes de toute façon c'est
long on gagne rarement de tour de france
à 28 ans on a on a depuis quelques
années un extraterrestre et peter sagan
qui lui arrive à briller depuis très
jeune âge mais il y en a très très peu
ont la maturité en cyclisme arrive très
tard on est plutôt autour de 26 27 28
ans et donc
donc même pour le sprinteur il faut
magasiner de l'expérience et aujourd'hui
donc moi je pense que et j'espère qu'ils
ne sont pas à maturité parce que
justement sinon on sera arrivé en haut
et ce serait dommage
mathilde mathilde est en train de faire
énormément de progrès mais elle a encore
énormément du cynisme que depuis trois
grands avant l'été ou pas c'est une
basketteuse avant donc
donc voilà elle a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à apprendre et bien là elle a
franchi un cap puisqu'elle a réussi à
aller chercher une médaille sur un
championnat international est un
championnat d'europe
elle perd pas contre n'importe qui et
perd contre la championne du monde donc
en titre qui est christina vos gueules
qui est une d'athlètes qui a plus de 30
ans j'ai pas son âge exact mais il ya
plus de trente ans donc une femme qui a
beaucoup d'expérience elle justement par
contre à ce niveau là et on ne peut pas
du tout du tout comparé et voilà c'est
déjà très bien de pouvoir arriver à
prendre d'expérience et surtout de
prendre expérience en gagnant parce que
oui bien sûr quand on perd comme j'ai pu
le faire aux championnats du monde
on apprend mais on apprend aussi en
gagnant est donc donc c'est beaucoup
plus facile d'apprendre en gagnant que
dans la défaite donc donc bah tant mieux
pour eux sébastien vigier ben on connaît
de moi je le connais depuis très
longtemps puisque je les accompagne et à
des compétitions ne s'était pas dans mon
club je l'accompagnais des compétitions
quand il était jeune cadet vous aviez
annoncé il ya deux ans dans les premiers
par les sports on m'a créé cette
émission tous ensemble vous avez mis
autour de la table que des gens qui
avaient des trois festivals
sébastien sébastien voilà fait des
choses qui sont exceptionnels il faut
savoir qu'il a fait 9 9 points 6
sur le 200 m des qualifications aux
championnats d'europe
jason kenny aux jeux olympiques à effet
9.5 donc c'est une performance qui est
très proche d'un stade francis de 9
secondes 6 pour faire les 200 m
qualificative c'est à dire que c'est là
dessus qu'on mesure en fait là la
vitesse maximum que l'on peut atteindre
sur 1 sur 1 sur un sprint et donc on se
fait une qualification avant de rentrer
sur le tournoi et ça permet aussi
d'éliminer les moins dé - les moins
rapides en général sur un championnat du
monde on prend 24 courant et donc il ya
toujours beaucoup plus de coureurs que
ça et donc les 29 à partir de 25 ils
sont ils sont éliminés
donc voilà sébastien aurait eu le
deuxième chrono à rio au jeu aux jo il
allait dernière fois il ya deux ans
l'année dernière il ya deux ans par les
dernières 2007 et donc pour comparer ces
10.7 à l'ag une seconde de retard et ça
fait maintenant deux ans que j'ai une
seconde de retard sur ces bassins viger
je progresse mais lui aussi
on en a discuté à l'entraînement la
semaine dernière on en a rigolé et n'est
pas encore à maturité et il ne manquait
pas de toi majorité et puisque ben voilà
comme je vous le disais on il arrivera à
maturité bien plus tard 26 27 28 ans et
donc il peut encore aller beaucoup plus
vite mais c'est tout ce qu'on lui
souhaite
et c'est ce qui va réaliser parce que
pass campus est un garçon qui a la tête
sur les épaules et qui est très très
très sympa et qui qui va qui va briller
à très haut niveau
les nations le regarde depuis d autres
les nations étrangères l on regarde
depuis très très longtemps et
et on en perd d'accord à pierre comment
on fait pour les gérer au mieux ces
nouvelles pépites voilà je disais 18 ans
vingt ans comment on fait pour les gérer
mentalement et physiquement mais la
journée je crois que je me suis d'accord
avec ce que disent et fred sur la partie
maturité qui doit être un alliage entre
le physique tient qu'ils ont une marge
de progression assez importante
le mental et l'expérience donc les gérer
ses essais en gros si je pars et si je
parle du rugby rugby au golf après sur
le sur l'individuel c'est c'est un
accompagnement et les pousser comme tu
disais à aller se frotter aux plus
grands prix en gros à tomber pour
pouvoir se relever ils apprennent autant
autant dans la victoire quand ça arrive
assez tôt très bien que dans la défaite
donc c'est vraiment un accompagnement
pour pouvoir justement façonner un petit
peu un athlète je pense affecté de ça
prend quelques années pour faire 1-1
athlètes et des titres dont classe et
c'est pour le coup un accompagnement de
tous les instants ça dépend si ces
sports causé aux sports individuels
aussi ça joue aussi un petit peu médias
il ya de l'entraînement il ya de
l'émulation jeu pendant les clubs pour
pouvoir se tirer vers le haut et façonné
justement cette maturité je souhaite
qu'effectivement il ne soit pas à
maturité à 18 ans parce que ça voudrait
dire que qu'ils ont presque tout vu ou
tout fait ça existe dans sa passeport la
maturité et en gymnastique par exemple
gymnastique par exemple en roller de
vitesse des performances pas se mesurer
un fusil fossé du rang de vitesse ont
performé les performances des juniors
sont très très très proche des
performances des élites et une carrière
de dans le roller de vitesse ça s'arrête
à 25 26 27 ans donc on n'est pas ça
dépend des sports est en effet la
gymnastique aux agrès
on voit bien ce sont toujours les plus
jeunes participants djo qui sont qui
sont qui font pas qu'ils font désormais
ce que c'est
alors juste pour sébastien sur sébastien
je voulais rappeler l'année dernière sur
une coupe du monde
il avait établi le troisième chrono sur
1 200 m et il s'était fait sortir en
huitième de finale voyez donc qu'il l'a
il a il a appris on a envie de discuter
aussi m'avait dit ben c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand on rentre dans un
tournoi dès le premier match il faut se
conditionner comme si on est en finale
et la ville se prend il pensait que
chronométriquement il aurait une
suffisance qui lui permettrait de
pouvoir contrer son adversaire et s'est
fait surprendre et il était rentré
bredouille et donc
et donc voilà il a il avait appris aussi
dans cette défaite est là il est aux
championnats d'europe il n'a fait mais
zéro faute maintenant il avait aussi la
valeur chronométrique pour pouvoir
contrer aussi ses adversaires et ça
c'est important de c'est beaucoup plus
facile il fallait qu anderson mathilde
grolleau entend beaucoup parler
aussi en ce moment là on a parlé
beaucoup de ça va s'infliger mais
mathilde de gros alors on la voit dans
tous les médias on la sollicite
énormément au niveau de la fédération
française
comment faire pour la gérer
psychologiquement parce que comme on
disait ça fait que trois ans qu'elle
fait du vélo est finalement allé déjà au
top ça soit sur la piste ou dans les
médias presse toujours la difficulté des
gens exceptionnels des gens d'exception
j'ai par exemple si on fait un parallèle
parallèle avec déjà partie la génération
2000 24 ans si on fait un parallèle avec
usain bolt
quand il arrive à faire son championnat
du monde il a le record mondial et après
on fait quoi quoi et en fait il faut
bien l'encadrer avec des entraîneurs
compétents et puis trouver des nouveaux
de chalain gtc de la maintenait la
garder motivés
bien sûr ça passe par continuer de
gagner mais peut-être chercher au dessus
laisser sa trace dans l'histoire en
essayant d'établir des records d des
performances qui dureront et qui
montreront à tous que va ouvrir la voie
peut-être pour les jeunes ça peut être
aussi une inspiration pour même si elle
a encore très jeune mais c'est vrai que
quand on a du succès gêne c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué à gérer sur le long
terme parce qu'une fois qu'on est enrobé
le problème c'est que quand on est en
haut de la montagne on peut plus aller
plus haut et plus que la descente donc
il va falloir à falloir faire attention
de ne pas chuter en route et essayer de
continuer à rester au sommet
comme elle l'est aujourd'hui ça va
oublier réagir ouais non simplement pour
elle
ajouter un point c'est que on est dans
une émission de sport et c'est ce qui
est la beauté justement de toutes ses
activités qu'elles soient physiques ou
intellectuelles un moment donné le
champion n'est pas celui qui est à
maturité physique ou technique
moi j'ai remarqué souvent que les gens
qui était exceptionnel on les retrouve
aussi et souvent beaucoup plus quand il
était mature mentalement et c'est à ça
que je fais référence quand je dis qu'on
a quelqu'un on a des gens d'exception on
les prend dans le sport par exemple vous
pourrez les mecs quand même bat p dans
le football on voit tout de suite des
jeunes qui ont la technique voit bien
qu'ils ont été achetés tellement cher
qu'on sait qu'ils en ont encore son pied
pour prendre des expressions cette
fois-ci footballistiques mais on voit
aussi l'esprit
on voit aussi la maturité et la graine
de champion 1 et marc était déjà comme
ça il ya quelques années et les gens
misent souvent non pas sur leur
technicité et non pas sur leurs
capacités physiques mais sur le mental
du champion sur le mental du devenir
c'est en ça que je disais qu'on avait le
sentiment d'une maturité ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on est en est arrivé et
qu'on est mûr dans son sport donc on est
arrivé au sommet de son art
techniquement il ya toujours des choses
à faire c'est le propre même du sport et
encore une fois j'englobe tous les
sports c'est le propre du sport que de
se dépasser soi même de dépasser des
records qui ont été identifiées il
pratiquait par d'autres en revanche le
mental moi je regarde tous les sports et
c'est à ce niveau là que j'ai c'est de
décrypter un peu les choses que ce soit
dans le sport automobile
et pourtant on est dans une bagnole que
ce soit au tennis que ça soit au foot
que ça soit dans le collectif donc dans
l'individuel que ça soit à cheval
je regarde beaucoup les compétitions de
cavaliers je retrouve toujours cette
graine de champion mentalement et c'est
un peu le message que j'aimerais faire
passer moi chaque fois qu'on parle de
sport que ce soit dans cette émission où
que ce soit dans la pratique même des
sports c'est que il ya des vertus au
sport où il ya des valeurs du sport et
on les trouve chez peu de gens et c'est
pas forcément technique ou physique
il faut durer quand vous m
nous sommes parfaitement le tout l'enjeu
et tu disais si fred je pense que c'est
tout l'enjeu c'est justement de leur
permettre de durer dans leur art je suis
assez d'accord avec l'expression est de
pouvoir leur donner les moyens soient
dans l'entraînement dans la préparation
mentale parce que c'est finalement la
boue là où ça se joue de pouvoir durer
dans chaque discipline pour m'attirer
rapidement les ravines informatique de
cette une
jeune fille très intelligente qui a
vraiment la tête les pieds sur terre et
la tête sur les épaules et fait voilà
est très bien encadrés afin très bien
entouré et l'entouré c'est la famille la
famille aussi est très très très très
sympa et donc voilà c'est exactement ce
que ce que tu disais et il n'y a
vraiment pas de crainte à avoir pour
elle maintenant je pense que la
fédération a vraiment raison mais
fédération française a vraiment raison
de faire communiquer par informatique
parce que le sport féminin de cyclistes
de féminin manque cruellement de
depuis ben aussi bien depuis que jeannie
longo avait arrêté et puis et puis
félicia ballanger aussi il manquait une
image je pense qu'on peut se servir
aujourd'hui de dogmatique de pour
justement de faire faire venir des
jeunes filles aussi bien sur la piste
qu'au vélo et maintenant il faut aussi
que pauline ferrand prévôt puisse puisse
revenir à très haut niveau et ça devrait
faire une belle une belle affiche en
tout cas mathilde de gros et les autres
pisteur de kido france on les verra lors
des championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste qui seront organisées sur la
piste d'apeldoorn aux pays bas voilà ça
sera en février prochain
on passe maintenant notre coup de
projecteur est encore du cyclisme
c'est presque une spéciale alors le tour
de france reviendra à l'été prochain
dans les yvelines après avoir boudé le
département depuis à 2013 et un départ
de versets les organisateurs ont décidé
d'inclure les routes yvelinoise dans le
tracé de la 105e grande boucle qui se
déroulera du 7 au 29 juillet ce sera sur
la dernière étape au départ de houille
et qui devrait descendre dans le sud du
département
au programme 115 km pour rejoindre le
grand final des champs-elysées à paris
la question sur ce thème ce choix de wii
vous plait-il pour prendre le départ
est ce que ça vous plaît tout simplement
ceux de m auj comme village départ de
cette dernière étape
oui oui non à en faire un petit but à la
rapine pierre et enfin yanis après
quelle que soit la quelle que soit vidé
des yvelines c'est une bonne chose que
ça puisse ça puisse être mis en valeur
et qu'on puisse retrouver le passage où
le départ d'une caravane du tour de
france après c'est toujours un gros gros
événement un gros bardonnie versailles
rambouillet pour vous qui avez déjà eu
sur les uns sur les autres villas les
années précédentes c'est une
c'est sûrement une une très bonne chose
pour les municipalités de douilles donc
normalement oui sartrouville poissy
chargement l'est peut-être une descente
vers le sud du département mais le tracé
n'est pas encore officiel officiellement
un très très beau catalogue de des
beautés de notre département
exactement allez-y ya maintenant parce
que c'est pas à côté de chez moi
c'est trop pour aller oui c'est le bout
du monde
donc non non moi et versa me doyer sur
les champs vous êtes plutôt même plus
danger l'arrivée je les fais plusieurs
années et c'était un très beau spectacle
maintenant
maintenant c'est vrai que mon
le dimanche ce dimanche là je te prie
fait beau je préfère je préfère aller à
aller voir aller aller ailleurs et puis
your voir l'arrivée d'étape
l'arrivée de l'étape sur en replay par
exemple ou à rentrer puisque ce soit une
étape qui finit qui finit tard et voir
juste l'arrivée d'étape tranquillement
pour moi le tour de france ne se termine
pas sur sur la dernière étape il est
fini bien plus tôt il sait jouer bien
plus tôt et donc c'est plutôt ces étapes
là que je ne je ne rate pas mais la
dernière étape maintenant m'intéresse
m'intéresse moi par contre c'est vrai
que aller au départ d'une d'une dernière
étape où les coureurs sont sont très
décontractée pour les spectateurs c'est
quelque chose que je les encourage à
faire parce qu'ils sont vraiment tous
très abordable et ça c'est pour les
enfants pour vos enfants
ça leur laisse vraiment de très bons
souvenirs et donc donc voilà c'est très
bien que ça reste dans le sens dans le
département mais mais bon voilà c'est
une c'est une dernière étape le tour de
france le tour de france je trouve ça
maintenant dommage c'est vrai que c'est
un petit coup de gueule que je peux
avoir
et ça fait des années et des années que
ça enfin ça fait depuis toujours comme
ça prend toute la place et toute l'image
médiatique du cyclisme le français est
aujourd'hui nos pistard ne sont pas
reconnus et ne sont pas connues parce
que beaucoup attendent les circuits sur
route mais et je trouve ça je trouve ça
dommage
vous voyez l'année où françois pervis
remporté trois titres de champion du
monde
il finit même pas vélo d'or
vélo d'or mondiale alors qu'il suffisait
du dernier tour de france pour être vélo
d'or alors cette année
chris froome double et donc je trouve ça
normal qui gagne qui qu'ils soient
récompensés parce que ça fait c'est très
très difficile de remporter deux grands
tours mais mais voilà il ya des exploits
qui passe un petit peu outre qui et tout
et tout est gâché tout est caché par le
pain le tour de france et les harkis
sont également sur la route benjamin
thomas par exemple dont on parlait de
bruit mais elle après ce sont des
disciplines qui c'est une discipline
alors la piste bien sûr c'est une
discipline ultra-complète bradley
wiggins vient de la piste qu'avait 18,1
de la piste et il court toujours surpris
s'ils sont champions du monde champions
du monde
en titre de la blague de l'américaine
donc donc c'est complètement possible de
pratiquer la piste et de courir sur sur
la route mais voilà ces coureurs là
ils ont ils conservent cette image et
ils ont leur image mais mais voilà c'est
vrai que le tour de france
écrase tout essai et c'est bien dommage
pour pour le reste de notre discipline
qui pourtant est un très beau sport et
le sport spectacle dans l'oeil sur piste
le spectacle sur la piste est vraiment
magnifique
mustapha on va revenir ce départ de la
ville de douilles dans les yvelines
du coup ce sera une belle fête populaire
je suppose
ah ouais non pour le coup moi je rejoins
je rejoins mon ami sa part ça permettra
d'avoir un champion en action oui et non
pour le coup c'est lui là j'ai vraiment
pas grand chose à dire sur le fait que
ce soit spécifique ah oui sauf que ça
puisse effectivement être dans le
département ce que c'est pas tout le
temps tout le temps dans le département
et en même temps c'est enfin c'est une
tellement belle compétition qu'on est
au-delà du sport est souvent quand on
parle de sport on arrive à la au
divertissement au divertissement on
arrive au jeu on arrive à l'argent et on
arrive au spectacle et c'est vrai pour
tous les sports de la même façon que le
football maman m'en donnez moi je
regarde pitron certains championnats
parce qu'on a l'impression que c'est
plutôt un jeu de un jeu de banquier plus
qu'un jeu de deux joueurs de foot
puisque après tout il n'ya pas la même
redistribution qui se fait de façon
aléatoire dans tous les clubs et là de
la même façon tout est captée par le
parlement par le le tour de france mais
en même temps c'est un peu ce que vous
recherchez tout c'est à dire que la main
j'entends un pratiquant on entend un
vrai sportif un compétiteur et qui voit
se détourner les projecteurs parce que
derrière il ya aussi tout un financement
de ce propre sport et la mise en avant
du sport mais le problème c'est que les
annonceurs les gens qui mettent de
l'argent sur le sport en général font
des choix et à un moment donné tout est
captée alors la dernière étape
elle est moins spectaculaire c'est vrai
que les mecs ils boivent du champagne
ils boivent du champ pour départ avec
modération voilà et avec modération je
sais pas mais souvent avec avait surtout
avec leurs copains et on voit bien
comment ça se termine avec un petit
sprint qui est pratiquement joué
d'avancé mais en même temps c'est ce
qu'on a voulu pendant des siècles faire
en sorte que le vélo soit connue et
c'est le tour de france qu'il a apporté
parce qu'il n'ya pas que les gens dont
c'est le métier qui en font une
profession et qui en font quelque chose
d'exceptionnel mais il ya tous les
consommateurs tous ceux qui ont envie de
consommer le vélo et c'est là où on est
toujours à la limite entre le sport le
loisir le divertissement voire spectacle
rapidement ryadi voulait répondre non
non je suis non ça vous êtes d'accord
non je j'attendais à une petite question
sur le parcours général tour de france
vous ne faites pas quitte à présent le
monde du cyclisme
voilà certains seront ravis de quitter
le cyclisme pour d'autres sports on va
parler à deux boxes un grand gala sera
organisé le 11 novembre prochain dans
l'air central du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines des dizaines
de combat seront programmés pour
l'occasion dans l'enceinte sportive
parmi les principaux rendez-vous la team
farruggia sera très bien représentée
avec les boxeurs à marvin petit gallus
coulon et marine tollé seul problème les
boxeurs n'ont pas été prévenus ac à l'as
vence de ce combat qui a été programmé à
la dernière minute
écoutez cet extrait du 7-8 sport est-ce
que c'est dommage qu'on prévienne tout
c'est dommage
en début de saison disons qu'en début de
saison peut-être en mars avril où on
repense comme tout le monde après les
vacances d'été
on reprend là c'est deux mois après la
reprise finalement donc de trois mois
après la reprise c'est toujours un tu
peux juste je pense qu'on est en phase
de remise en forme disons à s'arrêter en
mars avril serait peut-être pas été le
même le même topo maintenant
connaissant les deux gaillards quand je
vois ils sont enfants toujours ce qu'il
faut pour être prêt lors de leur combat
donc donc y'a pas de soucis pour ça la
question
sur ce thème le gala aurait-il dû être
décalée oui ou non
oui oui oui pareil frais la canasa louis
pas de débat fredrik andersson hed
ça s'est un peu short au niveau
préparation c'est un peu sur un coup
thèse on s'est dit on va faire un
tournoi de boxe
le vélodrome est libre alors pourquoi
pas on y va et c'est vrai que ça risque
d'être alors par l'école depuis
longtemps de ce combat mais
effectivement minute quand on voit
qu'ils ont eu que quelques semaines pour
pour se préparer on voit que les gros
matches de qualité généralement ça
nécessite plusieurs mois de préparation
réduire ce délai à plusieurs semaines
après je fais confiance aux boxeurs qui
sont des compétiteurs et des athlètes de
haut niveau pour produire 1 pour
produire 1 1 un spectacle de qualité
mais c'est vrai que l'on peut avoir pas
voir ses doutes et ses réserves avant la
tenue de l'événement a précédé événement
de cette ampleur là à voir que quelques
semaines pour faire la communication et
la promotion ces shorts
donc est ce que est ce qu'il aurait
mieux valu le repousser ou même ne pas
le faire du tout on peut on peut on peut
se dire qu'il ya une prise de risque qui
est un peu trop excessive juste pour
plaisir de pas d'organiser un événement
et puis peut-être dans des tickets plus
qu'une performance qu'on reconstitue
alizés il faut remettre dans le contexte
le fait que malamine koné voilà racheter
on va dire les gros combat en france et
il décide un peu du calendrier en fait
finalement pierre chevalier c'est la
question qu'on peut se poser
et je poursuis ce que ce que disent et
fred c'est est ce qu'on est ce qu'on a
le temps de pouvoir promouvoir cet
événement là est ce qu'on va pouvoir
qu'on a le temps de faire le plein ça a
pas l'air d'être d'être très fréquent
d'avoir un gala un gala de boxe de ce
type là on reparle cycliste puisque
c'est dans un vélodrome mais est ce
qu'on a le temps de justement de de
vendre beaucoup de tickets de faire là
de faire la promotion et d'avoir une
salle à peu près plein et et
sensibiliser à l'événement j'ai vraiment
peur que y avoir mille cinq cents
personnes à peu près 1
d'après l'elysée on affirmait encore
voir un vélodrome vide on va encore
faire une épreuve où il y aura il y aura
il y aura personne les gens seront déçus
et du coup on ne leur produira pas parce
que ben ça aura pas marché et c'est
dommage ça va quand même sur le négatif
euros mais encore une fois encore une
fois oui négatif suis désolé mais les
championnats d'europe
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
qui avait organisé en 2001 voilà les
week-ends
ça va être un vrai succès championnat
d'europe 1 en un an et demi après un
flop
il ya qu' il n'est plus une épreuve de
judo vélodrome était est et était
complet et c'était c'était formidable
mais bon la fédération française de judo
se suffit à elle-même pour pouvoir
remplir remplir n'importe quelle salle
et laure valcrème au vélodrome qui a qui
a fait le plein voilà mais avec le mal
si on dit oui ce sont des et puis ce
sont des grands mais ça avait été
prévenu des transports et cela était
prévu largement à l'avant cela on en
parle de trois semaines un mois pour
préparer ce type de gars là pour remplir
un vélodrome qui a toujours du mal qui a
souvent du mal à se remplir une salle de
spectacle qui a du mal à se remplir
1500 personnes dans le vélodrome bien il
ya personne nous
donc ça ne m'est pas d'ambiance et je
suis désolé ben quand on est spectateur
et qu'on a pas d'ambiance on est déçu
donc donc moi j'ai encore peur que ça
fasse ça fasse un flop et derrière ça ne
puisse pas être reproduits et
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est de la
récurrence même si même si je trouve
enfin le problème qu'il ya quand il ya
ce type d'événements organisés c'est que
moi je peux aller m'entraîner donc non
je voulais bien accepté de vous
entraîner spectateurs mais par contre un
flop
non ça c'est quelque chose qui qui va
faire rayonner ce vélodrome bah oui bien
sûr que je que je suis d'accord mais si
c'est pour que ce soit un flop derrière
non lâchant pas d'accord vous n'êtes pas
d'accord et l or bizarrement d'habitude
le vélodrome lui fermé les jours fériés
bah là il va être ouvert donc ça
m'aurait pas donc je n'ai pas pu
m'entraîner donc c'est pas c'est pas
très grave mais
mais voilà donc toutes ces choses là moi
ça me troue fin je trouve ça devrait et
voyez nous le grand prix de malaisie on
aura un certain nombre peut-être plus de
monde que sur certaines épreuves qui ont
été organisés de manière officielle
enfin avec des plus beaux plateaux donc
donc voilà il ya des choses qui ne sont
pas faites et parce que les choses sont
faites encore une fois en dépit du bon
sens
emma est alors le problème il ya c'est
que souvent les gens pensent que c'est
de la faute du vélodrome mais là en fait
c'est le promoteur qui prend sa décision
au dernier moment pour le faire et donc
les prédications également de droits
télé par exemple au combat va être
transmis chez nos confrères de canal
plus sport il ya les droits télé au
genou semaines de plus pour doivent être
comblées un solde qui sont au bénéfice
des athlètes qui sont au bénéfice des
organisateurs qui sont bénéfice de tout
le monde et du public
et au final tout le monde y gagne et on
décale que de quatre semaines voilà
c'est quand même pas enfin voilà après
je suis pas à la place de ces gens là
mais il ya un moment où je pense qu'il
faut que les gens réfléchissent et pour
le bien du sport en général mustapha sur
le on va revenir au plan sur le plan
sportif
voilà comment diesel se prépare à
dernière seconde on peut le dire
et du coup les entraîneurs ont choisi
ces deux là tiennent farouchement par
exemple tant que les femmes déjà choisi
des combats peut le dire facile des
matches de classement pour pour éviter
blessure pour éviter contre performance
de la part de ses protégés marine petit
par exemple la combattent un genre gien
géorgie à bram xv il y voit la chose que
vous connaissez mustapha 19 victoires
dont 9 par ko 14 défaites voilà 19
victoires 14 défaites s'il a 23 ans
c'est ça un petit peu le boxeur qu'on
envoie quand on n'a pas d'autres
possibilités de boxer c'est dommage
c'est en l'occurrence c'est dans la
continuité de ce qui a été organisé ces
accidents c'est dans le fil conducteur
de ce qu'était organisé on est tous les
quatre d'accord pour dire qu'il aurait
dû être reporté
c'est une émission qui s'appelle si on
parlait sport on devrait plutôt
l'intitulé souvent si on parlait
spectacle les mots qui ont été prononcés
depuis tout à l'heure c'est la notion de
vélodrome c'est la notion de spectacle
c'est la notion de public c'est la
notion alors qu on est en train de
parler d'un sport la boxe en occurrence
on a parlé tout à l'heure de deux vélos
et encore une fois oui le sportif où
sont les valeurs qu'on transmet ou sont
encore une fois les éléments
structurants du sport et c'est pourtant
l'essence même du sport que de générer
ça là on n'est pas d'accord
mais peut-être que la personne qu'il
organise aurait quelque chose à dire et
peut être qu'il nous manque un élément
c'est juste pour apporter un élément de
contradictions il ya tête un élément
réel et sérieux
mais c'est vrai que nous on n'en doute
simple mais à la limite on en doute même
pour lui c'est à dire que quand on n'a
pas suffisamment de temps pour préparer
ou le spectacle quand il s'agit d'un
spectacle où la promotion pour faire
venir les gens au spectacle mais surtout
les sportifs
c'est vrai qu'après on est à l'avenant
c'est à dire qu'on va mettre celui qui
est capable de 2,2 déboulé à n'importe
quel moment et faire n'importe quel
combat il y en a peut-être un qui sera
essentiel et puis on fera de la mousse
je peux parler d'expression tout autour
ouais ça ne grandit pas les
organisateurs ça grandit pas le sport en
général donc c'est en ça que ça devrait
être reportée bien sûr je retourne à
relent pour un match de boxe les gars
ils font deux trois matches dans l'année
c'est à dire que les deux temps de
préparation c'est souvent auto entre 3
et entre trois et six mois donc là on
leur dit alors bien sûr qu'ils sont sur
une forme constante mais un pic de forme
c'est quelque chose qui ce programme et
qui se fait pour ça que tanguy farruggia
l'entraîneur qu'on voit justement à
l'écran n'a pas voulu maintenant des
adversaires trop compliqué ici pour
gagner ce coulon qui affrontera tarek
derfoufi pareil pour le sport veut de la
complexité le sport veut de la
compétition le sport veut qu'on ait
jours aux tables du duel un beau duel à
quoi sert un beau match c'est quand on
attaque les tous les deux on peut avoir
des très beaux footballs très beau 0-0
et puis des matchs 5 0 qui arrive à rien
bien que quand on sort on dit ah tiens
on a vu des superbes d'action les arrêts
du gardien était magnifique mais là dès
qu'il y en a un qui va mettre un coup
loti va
il a vacillé une fois deux fois et puis
bal match ivan plié en trois minutes
ou alors on le dit et des sparring
partner on sait que c'est un match
qu'ils fassent part se passait en train
un challenger et ans par une partenaire
ou alors on a un lièvre dans une course
si on sait que c'est un lien on sait qui
par devant et on croit qu'il va gagner
mais non on a oublié de dire c'est un
lièvre il va s'écrouler et c'est donc
c'est vrai pour la notion même du sport
il ya quelque chose qui ne colle pas bon
il ya comme il ya quand même deux
combats qui valent le coup d'être vu
c'est celui d'adil abou madi qui à 37
ans va défendre sa ceinture ebu de
l'union européenne face à christophe
rebrasse un boxeur français de 32 ans
qui a un bilan de 25 combats et 5
défaites depuis le début de sa carrière
voilà on peut le dire c'est le seul
combat qui finalement fred anderson va
valoir le coup voilà c'est ça gallen
qu'ils fassent des démos qui fasse voilà
qu'ils fassent des choses pour que le
public sache qu'il ya un vrai combat sur
lequel on a misé un village bâti de la
défense de ceinture là ce soir donc à
l'ennemi qui on le sait est donc c'est
un gars là et puis pour le reste on va
amuser la galerie mais on le dit et on
fait des animations autour de ça ça me
choquerait - la limite c'est le gala le
spectacle mené par contre il ya un
combat qui est assez intéressant par
contre c'est celui de marine tollé qui
également de la team farrugia qui va
réaliser son premier combat pro frais
d'acte anderson dans la catégorie des
moins de 57 kg la boxeuse affrontera la
niçoise n'a idée gharshin championne du
monde deux pieds poings ça sera le son
premier combat pro et son adversaire
également ça sera un beau match sûrement
au boss si on sait certainement et puis
au moins ce sera ce sera le baptême du
feu et on verra en guerre de quoi elle
est capable comme elle 1000 1500
personnes qui devraient venir
peut-être qu'il va peut-être venir du
coup ce n'est pas trop la pression
la transaction
ça va lui permettre au oui certainement
tous les bat tous les combats surtout
quand c'est des premiers qu'on n'a pas
forcément beaucoup de beaucoup de
repères ça permet de
de prendre un peu la température du bain
mais l'entraînement ne remplacera jamais
la compétition faut pas oublier bien sûr
phase de la compétition
alors je le rappelle le grand gala de
boxe organisé le 11 novembre au
vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines
on passe maintenant notre focus du jour
dans notre focus du jour ce talk que
vous propose de découvrir la golf
golfeuses française alexandra bonetti
qu'à taper ses premières balles au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
je vous dresse son bilan rapidement elle
est aujourd'hui joueuse professionnelle
sur le circuit européen à 25 ans à les
membres de l'équipe de france depuis
2007 à la terminé troisième des
championnats du monde amateurs en
argentine en 2010 elle a décroché l'or
au championnat d'europe dames en 2014
après son bac elle a joué dans une
université au texas entre 2011 et 2015
et sillonne les greens américain pour
continuer à engranger les succès sur le
circuit et la joue et s'entraîne de
façon intense six jours sur sept de 8h à
17h on écoute alexandra bonetti
donc il ya cinq séances de sport par
semaine que je fais soit le matin avant
de venir au grade soit dans la soirée et
ensuite c'est un équilibre entre le
practice le petit jeu donc petit
shipping et le parcours donc ça
s'apprend pas mal de temps malgré le
fait qu'elle soit une très bonne joueuse
sur le circuit européen il doit payer
elle-même son matériel et ses
déplacements sur le terrain faute de
gros sponsors pour tenter de gagner plus
d'argent et pour jouer sur des meilleurs
tournois elle voudrait même partir jouer
aux etats unis une situation précaire
qui est à des années lumières on peut le
dire des standards des golfeurs
professionnels américains et européens
des golfeurs qui gagne presque dix fois
plus que les femmes sur les tournois en
moyenne principalement grâce à la
publicité autour des tournois masculins
la question sur ce thème le golf est
féminin havre at il un jour au niveau du
golf masculin voter oui ou non
oui non enfin un petit duel entre la
revanche est-ce qu'ils arriveront
jusqu'au niveau des hommes ce que c'est
vraiment ça l'objectif aussi je veux
dire les hommes ils sont tellement loin
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'ils sont
installés ont déjà tous tout en place on
a plutôt l'impression que sur le golf
féminin son camp pour jeunes ans et que
sa demande car ce cas se développer je
pense que plutôt que d'essayer de
rattraper les hommes c'est peut-être
plus une mission de
de se développer suffisamment pour cette
veine autosuffisant que le circuit en
lui-même
indépendamment de ce que font les hommes
permettent justement aux golfeuses et
eau et à tout leur staff et et à tout le
monde d'avoir les ressources nécessaires
pour s'entraîner décemment et et
progresser dans leur pratique sportive
et offrir des tournois de meilleure
qualité susceptibles d'apporter de
meilleures sponsors et ainsi de suite
je pense que le le circuit homme est
plutôt installés dans cette recherche de
performance avec déjà les sponsors ans
parce que les féminines sont plutôt dans
cet aspect de faire venir les sponsors
pour permettre à la performance de
s'établir et se développe et je pense
qu'ils sont à deux stades différents de
développement et je suis pas sûr que ce
soit très réaliste ni très très très
pertinent de vouloir comparer pas au
final deux mondes et deux visions du
golfe
si l' on verra après à votre message si
la question c'est ce qui est une égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes c'est une
vaste question qu'on pourrait poser bien
des égards dans d'autres sur d'autres
plateaux mais bien sûr que les les
femmes dans leur sport sont et vont
aller au maximum de ce qu'elles sont
capables de produire et c'est là où je
pose la question de sa main est ce que
c'est pertinent de dire mieux que les
hommes plus que les hommes moi je
considère qu' il ya une marge de
progression dans tous les sports que ce
soit pour les hommes et donc ils vont
aller jusqu'à un maximum de leurs
compétences qui sont physiques et aux et
mentale de la même façon les filles vont
faire de la même façon cette progression
mais j'aime pas cette idée de
comparaison cette idée selon laquelle il
y aurait un sport dominé par les hommes
et les femmes ne les atteindre est pas
pourtant au niveau des régions elles
sont les voir oui et puis on voit par là
on le voit pour le football aussi
d'ailleurs j'aime pas cette idée selon
laquelle non plus on dit on parle de
golf féminin ou de football féminin
c'est du foot c'est du golfe pratiqué
par des femmes et ces femmes là ont
leurs limites de compétences physiques
comme les hommes leurs limites de
compétences
mental comme les hommes et asie rond et
à feront leur chemin
la vraie question c'est les critères
selon laquelle à vont pouvoir pratiquer
ce sport pour que ça soit de ça devienne
plus culturelle que ça soit plus une
quelque chose qui soit plus sous la dent
dans l'air du temps qu'on se pose pas la
question de savoir si le foot ça peut
être pratiqué par des filles ou des
garçons ça c'est culturel s'est ancré
chez nous donc quand les filles feront
tous les sports la même façon et qu'on
se posera plus ce type de questions on
aura encore une fois sans les comparer
on aura le max des uns et des autres
c'est intrinsèque au sport on va
chercher le maximum et asie vont
chercher leur leur maximum pierre vous
avez marqué un petit message si vous m
il ya deux france qui il ya deux freins
d'argent que je vois sur le sur le
développement du golf féminin le 1er mai
historique presque culturel il faut pas
seul il faut pas oublier que que le golf
était était réservé aux hommes
dansez dansez première heure ses
premières années et le deuxième il est
physique au départ et ça devient
d'ailleurs ça devient un avantage pour
le développement du golf
au départ les femmes partent de repères
qui sont en avance sur le parcours par
rapport aux hommes
parce que yahia cette donnée de
puissance et de et de puissance qui est
de longueur oodrive seniors à la mise en
jeu et désormais on peut dire que c'est
presque un avantage que maintenant il ya
assez peu finalement il ya assez peu de
différences dans la pratique du golf
entre les hommes et les femmes à part
que les femmes partent 10 mètres 20
mètres devant les hommes en grande
compétition mais c'est mal c'est
saignant et c'est un sport que l'on peut
que l'on peut pratiquer à deux hommes
femmes et lui j'avais eu l'impression
que justement le golf est un sport très
technique et qu'il n'y ait pas besoin
d'être très physique
voire envoyer la balle très pressé de la
coordination et ses essais en haut une
un transfert de poids et de la puissance
qui envoie la balle le plus loin
possible
le golf féminin a de très belles heures
de 13 heures devant devant lui parce
qu'effectivement même si elles partent
de plus loin et elle partie
elles partent avec un avec avec un
handicap pour la golf elles sont elles
sont désormais au moins traités de la
même manière sur certains tournois
majeurs en france par exemple on a
depuis quelques années maintenant un
tournoi majeur mondial à evian donc les
gens de championship qui est légal d'un
certain nombre de tournois masculins
salsa mérite d'être encore développer
mais le coup de projecteur est donné à
ce moment là en septembre sur le sur le
tournoi féminin et au niveau mondial la
ryder cup qui arrive bientôt en france
et ben yahia l'équivalent en solheim cup
pour les pour les femmes et qui est
moins médiatisée parce que pour
l'instant les effectivement les les
annonceurs on en parlait tout à l'heure
n'ont pas fait le choix n'ont pas fait
le choix de denise et sur certaines
certaines filles et je dirais pour
terminer il manque encore comme chez
comme finalement chez les hommes depuis
le depuis le retrait de tiger woods qui
a priori revient une porte drapeau il ya
du michigan umich et louis a dû il ya il
ya du natalie gulbis chez les
américaines
il ya des filles qui arrivait en france
la monarque a remporté le bris donné
quelques chiffres
voilà la golfeuse cas rapportés remporté
le plus d'argent en 2016 c'est lydia kyo
la néo zélandaise aller remporté 2
millions d'euros en tournois et elle a
amassé 5 millions de dollars avec la
publicité soit même 43 millions de moins
que rory mcilroy ou halak ya remporté
rien qu'avec ces tournois 17 millions de
dollars en 2016 grâce à 8 seulement 3
par la victoire n'est l'apparition le
cirque
trois victoires sur cinq les mondial
voilà avec contre 2 millions de
publicités moi je voulais juste faire un
parallèle avec deux sports très
rapidement prom non vraiment le tennis
les tournois font des efforts pour que
les prix soient les mêmes pour les
féminines et les élus et les hommes et
pourtant le spectacle on aide a quand
même d'accord sur un tournoi de type
grand chelem n'est pas le même chez sur
un tournon sur une finale de deux filles
ou sur une finale d'hommes et d'ailleurs
le roland garros la journée qu'ils ont
l'air plus de mal à vendre des billets
c'est pour les demi finales féminines se
sont souvent les derniers billets qui
sont qui sont qui sont à vendre et donc
et ensuite je voulais faire parler avec
un autre sport qui lui pourrait lui est
beaucoup plus féminin et on en parle est
alors c'est la gymnastique aux agrès
sincèrement je préfère de loin regarder
aux jeux olympiques
la gymnastique féminine plutôt que la
gymnastique masculine qui elle est
beaucoup plus basé sur le physique
alors que la gymnastique féminine est
beaucoup plus basé sur la technique est
donc beaucoup plus joli donc voilà je
pense aussi il ya un moment et je veux
pas qu'on me traite de macho je pense
qu'il ya quand même des sports qui sont
quand même plus ou moins
sexuée mais qu'est ce que tu penses mais
cgg grande de penser aussi sur le genre
là ça qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure de la
capacité que les femmes auraient à
accéder soit des podiums on parlait
française en l'occurrence un des podiums
voire à des statut de star et on parle
quand on commence à parler tarification
quand on commence à parler de ces gens
m'en parlent du montant de ce qu'elles
sont capables de gagner
c'est en simple je dis que c'est une
histoire de visibilité c'est une
histoire de donc ça n'a plus rien à voir
et demi avec le genre ni avec la
personne et donc après pour que le golf
puisse continuer de goran le golf
féminin puisque ont fait grandir il faut
aussi que les organisateurs fassent le
nécessaire mais la différence qui lie
avec le golf c'est que on ne peut pas
organiser sur le même tournoi les hommes
et les femmes parce que la conception
n'est pas n'est pas du tout la montée ça
et on essaie résistante et les ans et je
suis désolé populaire à l'école
paupières à l'école les filles sont
hyper de man 2 est très doué dès le
départ certaines écoles
ça sera le mot de la fin sur ce thème un
méli quitter sa part ce n'est qu'en
location c'est que ces sujets vous tient
à coeur mais il faut avancer dans
l'émission alors on va passer maintenant
à notre rubrique débats
d'un débat on passe un lieu de débat
nous allons prendre le large dans ceux
ci ont parlé sport le skipper louis
burton originaire de rambouillet prendra
le départ de la 13e édition de la
transat jacques vabre le 5 novembre
prochain sur son imoca bureau vallée une
aventure transatlantique entre le port
du havre et le brésil qui partagera en
duo avec sa femme servane escoffier leur
objectif accrocher le podium de la
course pour lui partir avec sa femme est
un avantage
en écoute il ya évidemment des écueils
dans lesquels il faut pas tomber on est
on est un couple à terre mais c'est vrai
que quand on va là partir en mer ce sont
des courses qui sont quand même
extrêmement dur donc il faut pas faire
de sensibilité trop
poussez faut vraiment se dire qu'on a un
équipage donc c'est le deal qu'on a fait
et puis ensuite le côté sympa c'est
comme on se connaît très bien on va être
un héros être plus libres de s'exprimer
sur notre façon de voir les choses nos
façons de voir la course les options la
stratégie la météo on n'a pas ce frein
qu'on peut avoir quand on part avec
quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas ou peu c'est
un avantage c'est une certitude sinon je
ne l'aurais pas je ne ferai pas la
question sur ce thème très rapidement
partir avec sa femme est il un avantage
ou un inconvénient
vu le temps qui nous reste dans cette
émission on va faire juste un tour de
table moustapha que ça dépend de la
relation point ils sont bien ensemble ça
se passe bien ils sont entre autres aux
biens s'il ya des choses qui émergent
c'est le cas de le dire parce qu'ils
partent eux surtout chez mr j'aurais
appelé des eaux au gré des flots comme
ça je sais pas mais à priori oui bien
sûr sur la paix des ménages ou et ça
c'est effectivement très important mais
je crois qu'à lévis lauzon
voilà exactement voilà déjà fait assez
rare avec son père un pub c'est ça aussi
en 2003 elle a fini troisième de
l'édition 2005 elle s'est classée 2e de
la route du rhum en 2006 et elle a
disputé la compétition en 2010 si un
gars hexis toute façon comme question
voilà c'est ce qui fait la bouche sur le
bateau de personnes pensent que ça
revient toujours à la question par
exemple dans les sports collectifs il ya
des gens avec qui on s'entend pas du
tout en dehors du terrain sur terrain ça
marche
instinctivement et à des gens sur qui
bat sur le terrain ça marche pas
et l'inversé est vrai aussi dire que
yahia il ya deux mondes séparés c'est
pas parce qu'on s'entend bien en dehors
du terrain vous entendra bien sur le
terrain et c'est pas parce qu'on
s'entend bien sûr tinqueux
nécessairement dehors on s'entendra mais
aussi je pensais plus ou question
d'alchimie entre les deux personnalités
c'était un petit peu aussi son cerveau
sur le dernier vendée globe c'est elle
qui se réveille en pleine nuit pour lui
écrire des mails sur la compétition
c'est elle qui le conseille non mais
voilà voyez vous il vous pouvoir
mélanger et bien j'ai leur expérience
maintenant parce que je trouve génial
c'est de pouvoir justement partagé ses
ce type d'expérience avec la personne
que l'on aime vous voyez le faire depuis
et ben voilà ben ils vont ils vont
pouvoir enfin concrétisé concrétiser ce
rêve est donc ils vont certainement
vivre une très très belle expérience
voilà donc c'est superbe de pouvoir
ouais c'est super de pouvoir partager
cette expérience ensemble et donc de
vivre de vivre cette cet échange
comme ça faisait six ans qui voulait le
faire ben tant mieux pour eux et ils ont
fini et je pense que l'histoire soit
l'histoire une histoire sera encore plus
belle si ils arrivent à être sur le
podium
c'est l'objectif en tout cas c'est la
fin de cette émission se retrouvent le
jeudi c'est souvent pour une émission
spéciale à ryder cup la coupe du monde
du gol qui s'organisent en septembre
2018 au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
on va terminer par une citation du
champion du monde de boxe anglaise lui
julien lorcy la vie c'est comme la boxe
en quatre mots avance encaisse esquive
et progresse je vous laisse
à bientôt sur tv à 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui